I always thought you know a snowshoe
would really make a great cello a wooden
chair back makes a cool guitar body it
turns out that one of my most playable
instruments is is a golf club I'm seeing
that transformative quality in my head
all the time
what can I say out I'm attracted to
trash there's no way
[Music]
check out the Jimi Hendrix of shuffle is
a guitar made up of lots of we'll jump
he even plays his zipper from Brooklyn
New York welcome Ken Bob Meyer my name
is Ken Butler I'm an artist and musician
and known for building my own
experimental instruments since 1978 I
think I've made around 400 instruments
this whole thing started for me when I
was in my basement in Portland Oregon
and I saw a rusty old beat-up hatchet
put two strings and two tuning pegs on
it plugged it into my guitar amp and was
quite stunned that it actually sounded
like a horrible violin the ax violin was
the first time that somebody said that's
a cool idea if I go walking around the
neighborhood everywhere you look you see
such amazing conglomerations of
potential sculpture there's crutches
tennis rackets parts of furniture boom
I'm right there with it you know when I
build stringed instruments really just
need three things the head the neck and
the body a spoon has that parameter a
key looks like a guitar as you know and
then it's little body
this is from a very inexpensive mandolin
of course some of the things become
crazy Baroque assemblages of multiple
multiple necks it's ridiculous
but that's how it works my shovel guitar
I guess it's a small snow shovel it's
just a four key object and it sounds
unbelievably beautiful the qualities and
characters at the Golf Club has is
amazing this one is made from a beach
paddle that has a ukelele neck and a
team sometimes people think my intention
is humour it's not I think it's
surprising to people when I can generate
genuine emotion and meaning and real
music on something as ridiculous as a
hockey stick or tennis racket or a broom
or a shovel or a golf club at the real
core of what I'm doing is to communicate
to other people that the things right
around them can be magical and
transformative and even spiritual hill
knows if if I hadn't found that axe what
would have happened
to play the instrument that is utilizing
our gentle earth it's like you are
becoming one with the instrument in a
very true way you just sit and go yes
[Laughter]
[Music]
we're looking at the grates two leg pipe
organ of the Luray Caverns in Luray
Virginia when I press a key it sends an
electrical pulse up to a rubber tipped
mallet which strikes the stalactite
causing it to vibrate and producing a
incredibly beautiful musical tone the
area that the strikers cover is roughly
three and a half acres which then makes
it literally the world's largest musical
instrument it is a very gentle sound of
very peaceful
there's only one like it in the world
and it's something incredibly different
and wonderfully beautiful very often
people think it's gonna be funny and
then they realize it's not really you
really do music it's not impossible to
make music with vegetables
[Music]
my name is Susana got Naya and then I'm
a member of the vegetable orchestra the
orchestra exists since 18 years now if
there's instrument was the tomato
because you can do sound with tomatoes
but it will be messy
for sure we go shopping on the market
first we choose all the vegetables there
we have three kinds of instruments one
is the ready mate you can just buy it at
the market and play it it's like the
pepper it's cold it's ready already and
then there are the simple instruments
like with one cut or some cuts to get it
like that then with the more complex
instruments we have some that work like
normal instruments you know the pumpkin
is the bass drum and the sound of the
pumpkin is really important after
shopping we go to the venue and start to
build instruments all in all it takes 2
to 3 hours to paint all the instruments
for everybody and then we start with the
soundcheck and since we have new
instruments each time we have to have a
very long soundcheck
[Music]
[Applause]
we have a lot of different musical
influences in the orchestra since
they're really many people everybody's
interested in different things we make
soup during the building process of the
vegetable instruments with the remaining
vegetables when we serve it to the
audience after the concert and it's also
after hearing and seeing us and smelling
the vegetables which will be intense in
there because it's so small this theater
and then you can also eat it you never
get it out of your head anymore if
you're in the orchestra to look
vegetables in another way
[Applause]
I'm sure if someone were to look inside
my window while I'm playing they
probably would have no idea what's going
on in here to watch a theremin being
played looks really strange
[Music]
my name is Palelei and Stickney and one
of the instruments I'd love to play is a
Sarah Minh like what the hell was that
that's I don't know so the diamond is a
synthesizer and it's a synthesizer
that's not controlled with the use of a
keyboard like a piano I'm controlling
the pitches with my left hand and this
hand is just the articulation hands the
volume
[Music]
it's controlled without any physical
contact and you can make it like the
birds the really big challenge with the
instrument is its reacting not just to
my hands and how they're moving in my
fingers it's sensitive as well in a to
my whole body I've recorded on an album
of David Burns Grace Jones the Indigo
Girls it's such a new instrument still
that there's nobody who's going to stand
there and say you're not doing it the
way it's supposed to be done I don't
think there's anything else like it it
doesn't relate to anything else I've
ever played
you
there's the rulers the reverb tank the
e-book a normal instrument you're
playing it and you're expecting it to
have a sound that is pleasing but with
an instrument like this the goal is to
just produce sounds that's in this case
disturbing
[Music]
the apprehension engine it's an
instrument that creates a variety of
really creepy and someone say horrifying
sounds
my name is Marc Corvin I'm a film music
composer and lately I've been focusing
on horror movie scores two of my biggest
hits as far as horror films are
concerned was from the late 90s a film
called cube and most recently the which
I originally commissioned the
apprehension Asian because I was tired
and the same digital samples which which
resulted in a lot of sameness of a lot
of horror music so I was looking for
something more experimental more
acoustic that would give me a little bit
more of an original sound that's where I
contacted my friend Tony Duggan Smith so
Marc called me asking me to create a
crazy instrument for horror films
because I've never done anything like
that before
it may be empty out my pockets and all
my drawers of any knickknacks and bits
and bobs I could possibly string
together to make it happen for him and
this is what camera
[Music]
you're doing those things that stir-fry
my emotions and the feelings and there
actually is a skill set that you have to
acquire in order to to get the most out
of it
it expresses what really can't be
expressed any other way it's not music
in the traditional sense at all but let
me put it this way the apprehension
engine definitely evokes an emotion so I
would call it easy
you
you